pour mon ciré je voulais souhaiter une
belle rentrée dixième saison juste la
grande classe
salut une très bonne saison 10 à toi
c'est lille et à toute son équipe
je vous embrasse salut mon cyril voilà
c'était pour te souhaiter une très très
belle saison et un dixième anniversaire
j'imagine à toi et à tes pmp tous
ensemble vous embrasse très fort et atos
et surtout mon baba bezos j'ai dû jouer
pour le lancement
salut frérot je vais te souhaiter une
bonne rentrée bravo pour les disant
félicitations à tous et plus homogène
donc on n'en sait rien belles choses à
vous pour cette dixième saison quand
enfin de belles choses pour cette
rentrée
je fais des bisous les mises au jeu pour
le but précis forme c'est à peu près
d'ici for men un petit baiser
toutefois cinq ou six ans voilà je vais
faire partie de la rubrique bricolage à
la batterie je leur raconte des trucs on
va prendre a montré des casiers des
trucs à san siro ce salut a tous des pep
des big black amont personnes longue vie
à vous bonne saison dif
à très bientôt je vous souhaite une
belle saison 10 je passe vous voir très
bientôt en attendant je suis en répète
pour ma tournée comme vous pouvez le
constater prenez soin de vous belle
saison cha la famille pour lé content
d'être
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]